Starbucks is quitting its joint venture in South Korea,...
...the firm's fifth largest market.
It's selling a part of its stake to a local partner Emart.
The rest is being snapped up by Singapore's sovereign wealth fund GIC.
Retailer Emart will operate the stores...
...and buy an additional 17.5 percent stake for 411 million dollars.
That suggests a 2.35 billion-dollar value for the whole business.
Starbucks said the deal would be completed in 90 days.
Its South Korean office wouldn't comment on why the firm was selling up.
With more than 1,500 stores across 78 cities,...
...Starbucks Coffee Korea saw operating profits surge...
...nearly three quarters over the January to March quarter.